Wow Sugarman mind it spirit of that it's
Monday and it's time to Fabul eyes and I
didn't know what who did what to do what
so I listen to you bro suggestions and
apparently you bros won't see me
finalize some youtubers the one you
suggested number one it's of course the
fab master me so I'm gonna start with
myself okay so I have this really really
nice picture of myself that I think we
can work with let's no wait okay there's
so many ideas I could do with this
obviously alright let's do what I
thought about first it's already like 10
times better
dad nip-slip though alright
what is women like women ones must
muscles let's get some muscles okay that
looks really awkward allah i love the
the different nips going on i don't know
what happened there to be honest i don't
know what to do with this let's add a
little that's a little toe just to make
it extra realistic perfect alright so
now to find the perfect background i
don't i don't even know why am i doing
this i wanted to be my ein since my I
only have one eye we have to fix that
somehow I don't know how okay start nice
finishing touch with some you can never
go wrong with sparkles never yeah I
don't even have to place them correctly
okay
what what Wow Wow okay you ready
da da
that is a bra I guess technically it's
like a boob thanks
what do you mean there that's not
Photoshop what are you talking about
this is gonna be on my new wallpaper
okay all right so Edgar pull out the
cable to my computer while I was editing
and now now I don't now I have to redo
everything but that's okay because you
know what do you know who we're gonna do
next
Oh God so my says face it wasn't
straight so I have to fix it all day
beautiful all right it's my girlfriend
right there ever so beautiful we need
some tiny touch up effects though don't
go real maniples
no no no no kids don't do it kids don't
know what is happening no someone's this
was it wasn't supposed to be this way
you are the chosen one oh god no what
have I done
what the [ __ ] [ __ ] why are we gonna keep
this just discovered the greatest thing
I'm crying a little bit oh [ __ ]
no not that one it's too much it's not a
little 30 they're like barely this is
okay it's done it's done
what's done is done that no no this is
not Facebook friendly I'm sorry all
right let's add mad at my mouth said to
the family she'll be right there
let's fix up the colors a little bit my
my girlfriend is beautiful 99.99 percent
of the time so she's okay with being not
not as not as beautiful for a lull bang
okay so chill deal today man look at
those ABS geez all right pres I'm sorry
this one was a little shorter I lost a
lot of time cuz I Edgar and it's pretty
late right now but I hope you guys
enjoyed watching anyway leave it like a
few one more fabulae sir I love doing
these is so much fun
hit subscribe to become a road today you
know I'll see bras in the next one